So I'm almost in a sense redoing a story from
January this year,
which is that Carla Harris is again being
accused of flip flopping and backing away
from Medicare for all.
But this time I actually don't think she is.
I think there is a flip flop here, but it's
a different one from the one that most people
are talking about.
So let me set this up for you.
Um, we need to be really clear about the terrible
way in which the healthcare questions were
asked to the Democratic primary candidates
in night one and night two of the debate.
The main problem is the way that those questions
were framed was bound to lead to confusion.
And I wish that candidates had actually called
out the framing of those questions, but I'll
back up and we'll get to that.
Back in January, Kamala Harris did a CNN town
hall and during the CNN town call town hall,
she was asked about Medicare for all.
And here's what she had to say.
What is your solution to ensure that people
have access to quality health care at an affordable
price?
And does that solution involve cutting insurance
companies as we know them out of the equation?
I believe the solution, and I'm, and I'm actually
feel very strongly about this, is that we
need to have medicare for all.
That's just the bottom line.
So that was very definitive.
But then the day after that she backed off
and advisor of hers put out a statement and
saying, well, she's open to more moderate
ideas as well, like preserving d in the industry
we have and making tweaks to Obamacare and
it appeared to be a significant backing off
from Medicare for all.
So then the debate happens late last week
and the day after Carla Harris is interviewed
and once again the accusation start flying
that Kamala Harris is flip-flopping that during
the debate she raised her hand and said, I'm
for Medicare for all.
And that the day after the debate she backed
off of that and said, I'm not actually for
Medicare for all.
There is a flip flop here, but it is not the
one that is being reported at Camila.
Harris w said she was for Medicare for all
in the town hall in January.
The next day she did sort of back off of it.
And now she is again saying that she, she's
for Medicare for all.
Uh, the confusion is again, how that question
was asked.
So net let's now look, and this is mostly
visual, this is when the candidates were asked,
raise your hand on healthcare, but listen
to how the question was framed.
Who here would abolish their private health
insurance in favor of a government plan?
Yeah.
Right.
So Kamala Harris raises her hand there.
And as I said at the time, this was a terrible,
terrible question.
This led to confusion.
This led to people being able to just go a
cop out claim they didn't understand it, whatever.
And case in point, Kamala Harris was interviewed
on CBS the day after the debate and she said,
Oh yeah, I raised my hand.
But the question was, would I give up my private
insurance for a government plan?
Not should I, uh, would I want private insurance
abolished?
And then she gets into an argument with the
interviewer.
The interviewer says, no, no, the question
was should private insurance be made illegal?
And I called this question out because it
was improperly asked for exactly this reason
and then Camilla Harris gives us, I guess
what you would call her real position on this
issue at this point in time.
Senator a another defining moment in the debate
was when every candidate was asked to raise
their hand if they would abolish private insurance.
In that moment you raised your hand, but afterwards
your campaign says, actually that's not your
position.
So what is your position on private insurance?
So the question was would you be willing to
give up your private insurance?
That's not how it was such a plan and that's
what you heard.
Right.
Okay.
Then yeah, that's certainly what I heard.
And I'm in terms of, I am supportive of Medicare
for all and under Medicare for all policy,
private insurance would certainly exist and
for supplemental, um, coverage, but under
Medicare for all and my vision of it, we would
actually extend benefits.
So, for example, vision care, dental care,
hearing aids, which currently are not covered
in, and anyone you know who is a senior can
tell you they're extremely expensive and people
have to come out of pocket to pay for them.
I'm included in my perspective on the issue
of private insurance is this, and I told the
story last night, look, any night in America,
there is some parent who's got a child who
has a fever that's out of control and going
to the emergency room to get help in the middle
of the night.
And then looking at those sliding glass doors
as they're in their car, in the parking lot,
concerned that if they walk through those
sliding glass doors, they're going to be out
of pocket $5,000 because of the deductible.
They've got insurance, all right?
They're going to be out of pocket $5,000 we're
going to have to leave it there.
So you know, 91% and I'll just add 91% of
the doctors in America today are in Medicare,
so you won't lose your doctor.
So I don't actually see this as a flip flop
from the debate in the way that I understood
the question, but the whole point is the question
was terribly asked what did they actually
mean by the question?
Were they saying would you personally given
the option of giving up your private insurance
for a government plan opt for that plan.
That was a reasonable way to understand the
question.
Others understood it to be this sort of right
wing meme talking point of Democrats would
make private illegal if such a government
plan was put forward and the question by virtue
of being a terrible question and improperly
asked led to exactly this type of thing.
So I don't see the flip flop that some people
are claiming.
I don't see that Camilo raising her hand means
yes to Medicare for all.
And then in the interview she said she's against
it.
My interpretation of the Commonwealth flip
flop is that in the town hall she said, I'm
for Medicare for all and got the political
benefit of that the next day.
A statement was put out in January saying,
well, she's open to other options as well,
but she likes Medicare for all and now apparently,
uh, putting her finger to the wind and recognizing
that this is not a good path forward if she
is not for Medicare for all.
Look at how Joe Biden is suffering as a result
of his position on healthcare.
She now again is saying, Oh yeah, I am just
for Medicare for all.
So bottom line, it does seem that commonly
Harris is on the Medicare for all train right
now.
But remember she can very easily pay lip service
to it and say, I'm in favor of it without
having any real plan or goal of implementing
it.
If she were to become president of the United
States, we need clarity from our elected officials,
from the candidates in particular about what
their policy is.
And you have to understand, is someone saying,
I'm for Medicare for all.
If you don't follow that up and say, okay,
if instead what was proposed were simply some
tweaks to Obamacare, would that be okay with
you?
Unless you ask that follow up.
It's very easy to say, I'm for Medicare for
all and I'm for the public option and I'm
for tweaking Obamacare and I'm for also not
really making too many changes other than
maybe expanding access to Medicaid.
You've got to go further and this is why the
debate question fell so, so flat where now
we're arguing about which is the flop.
If there is one that Kamala Harris made, rather
than a better asked question during the debate
would have given us much more valuable information
about what these candidates actually stand
for.